[Applause]
do you want to speak with confidence
like these amazing personalities every
single one of these amazing speakers
have taken the same program with brother
Muhammad Arad Muhammad Arad has help
develop all of us it's extremely
beneficial to do this course definitely
recommend this course
to access the free life-changing
training now asalam alaikum brothers and
sisters and dear friends listen to one
of this this member of the UN official
now listen to them very carefully
because when I heard them I genuinely
was thinking thank God for that like
someone has some Humanity in them little
did I realize she's not talking about
Palestine listen to this for yourself
this hypocritical double standard woman
I would like to call her something else
but I'm going to refrain watch this for
yourself war crimes targeted attacks on
civilian infrastructure with a clear aim
to cut off men women children of water
electricity and heating with the winter
coming these are acts of pure Terror and
we have to call it as such this is a
moment to stay the course and we will
back Ukraine for as long as it
takes
[Applause]
so guys can you imagine she's saying the
same words Benjamin Netanyahu the filthy
scum dog
Satan may Allah make him destroy him in
this D and in the Hellfire inshallah I
cannot wait to see the scum in the pits
of Hellfire burning dying for all the
mass that he's caused him and his
buddies have been seing no food no
electricity no water no supplies and
this woman from the UN this woman she
doesn't when I watched that video I was
thinking she's talking about Palestine
and I realize she's talking about
Ukraine when Russia's doing crimes it's
terrorism it's wrong it's barbaric how
could you do this Winter's coming gas
deliveries to certain EU member states
is another provocation from the Kremlin
but it comes as no surprise that the
Kremlin uses fossil fuels to try to
Blackmail us rightly so but when it's
Israel what does she say Israel has a
right to defend themsel what about these
people you can see they don't even see
the Palestinians as human beings W it is
unbelievable it is unbelievable these
double standard Hypocrites these scums
do not care about your brothers and
sisters they do not care the blood of
the Believers are cheap but you guys who
are watching at home you can make
changes there is a link in the
description box give whatever you can
inshallah we will support Palestine we
will support our brothers and sisters
who have been massacred with our duas
with our prayers and by these videos
we're going to raise awareness you will
not stop us you are not going to stop us
Israel is a terrorist State and they
know that and the entire world know that
but because it's Muslim blood dis
spilling it's fine but when it is
blueeyed blond haired white skinned
people in Ukraine it is not justified
but if it's a Palestinians it is that
day will come inshallah the day of
judgment is there for a reason be
patient inshah and may Allah forgive us
for not doing enough please donate the
link below alum Pat